- It is the worst when cops pull you over
just to get your number.
It's like, I have somewhere to be.
("Prohibition Rag")
- God, this chick's like obsessed with me.
She won't leave me alone.
- I mean, it's great
that he has a big dick
and everything, but it is so hard
to walk the next day.
Like, uh, so sore.
- I've been so busy and exhausted
ever since they promoted me.
- I did my interview for
this job so hung over
and I still got it.
- You should use my cabin in Aspen.
I'm barely ever there.
And I hate that it sits
empty most of the year.
- I've been sticking to this
diet for four weeks now,
and I'm really seeing results,
but ugh, I'm so hungry.
- Ugh, it's so gross.
My skin's peeling from when I
was on the beach in Honolulu.
- Oh, I get pulled over so much more
now that I have my BMW.
It is crazy.
- I spent my entire Sunday in a hot tub,
so I'm really dehydrated today.
- This guy I met on Saturday
said the craziest thing.
He was like, "Oh my God, you're so cute.
"I'm usually gay, but for you,
"I would totally be straight."
- Sorry if I seem out of it today.
Last night I saw Drake at a bar
and he was just buying shots all night.
- Shopping sucks.
Do you know how hard it
is to find an extra small?
- Tinder's stupid at a point, right?
Because you just keep swiping right
and it's just like match,
match, match, match, match.
I'm just like what is the
point of Tinder anymore?
Like I can't talk to all of you.
("Prohibition Rag")